welcome to this video playing Alexei one
Alexei one mark timmermans mark
Timmerman's to 6 44 feet master huh okay
yeah let's see what happens that's kind
of weird don't see a regular feeder
master get into to 650 and the
five-minute pool but let's see what
happens having played them before they
don't know the planets that's kinda
kinda weird yeah this kind of things
they exist here but typical case often
not very correct cam bird in the hand
open games but it said sometimes not so
easy into to play for black yep like
it's just a pole up here
get this out of them efile you got a
pawn and two bishops here we have
success may be the easiest term viet
gamer this guy is to 650 and five minute
and just gives away upon for nothing in
the opening yeah interesting i can go
queen a3 hunting pawns it's it's not a
totally easy task because of my slightly
weak power structure check if I've Eve
for maybe it's got Queen you three maybe
should I play c5c 5c for maybe making
sure that i'm not getting blocked
c6 and then c4
so just Bishop c8 it's not like i love
this Bishop so much I mean I like my
bishops but I sort of want to try to
show that this night it's not doing much
on c5 what now Queen g6 may be checking
on c2
and on age three now I control the open
a file
yeah I can just take the pawn I mean why
not don't see draw back and now just
open return to f5 or to g6 night a 4
might check my pony but I have Queen d6
check check then I can just cover it
with Quincy 7 keeping my material
together not not sacrificing anything
again he's not threatening much think
and this is this is this is how we can
do is a game like that you're sort of
thing okay this guy's just playing
nonsense all the time and you blend the
two rook takes d5 yes great check yeah
the good thing is that I'm still better
but the trend is not not positive let's
see cookie three years unfortunately
covered I would like to get the Bishop
to g5 but if I play this I can do that I
thought rookie to what I have worked yet
OOP th has a good thing we should be
five he will take I have rookie too
though
rook da is also good yeah 137 okay check
keep it simple him check check check
give it time off chicks check
okay of course I should have won this
game long journey but I really played it
played it badly
just blundering d5 was terrible it's the
pawn yeah but also the ha ha her
position now let's take a strong
following winds on time at some point
yeah yeah i mean what this was really
kind of thing that frustrates you have
your opponent place the worst possible
way basically here and you just have to
not blunder this pawn and he's really
reduced to this rook takes d5 idea and i
blundered I'm still winning after that
but I mean something like this I mean
what what kind of stuff is that they can
just resign hear you but I blunder I
thought that I will win anyway and any
in any fashion basically and I'm just
giving up this pawn it's chance probably
still winning i'm brookie forster wins
intending [ __ ] h4 yeah i really don't
understand something so i mean this guy
is 2600 Tiant is basically lost after
move seven I don't understand it why do
you play an opening that is so easily
refuted Black is just a pawn up for for
nothing yeah and I even have the better
minor pieces but you don't know what
some of those accounts are some officia
this is an account that is really old
there are some from 2004 and it is very
often the case that those accounts are
shared I mean I don't even know this guy
marketing moments I don't know where
weird stuff okay well thanks for
watching